[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العرب يا بودكاست لبست فايتر
احسن مقاتل هو اللي عمره ما بيغضب
والمقاتل البطل بتاعنا طول الوقت غضبان
الفيلم قائم على قصه حقيقيه لملاكم كان
بطل الوزن المتوسط وخرجت للنور على ايد
المخرج العبقري مارتنز كورسيزي باقناع من
بطل الفيلم
فاهلا بيك في حلقه جديده من بودكا الافلام
انا محمود النجار واخدك النهارده في رحله
لمامارا ريجين بو من بدايه الفيلم وكل
ادوات المخرج سكرسيزي بتاكد على اهم شيء
في الفيلم وهي المليو دراما اول مبالغه في
العرض والاداء السينمائي اول لقطه بيقدمها
لنا عباره عن جاكله بيجهز لماتش ما في
مسيرته بموسيقى تصويريه دراميه جدا وبناخد
اول قط بعد المشهد الرياضي في ابهى صوره
له علشان نشوف جاكله موته في سن اكبر بجسم
اقل رياضيه واكثر بدانا بينفخ سيجاره
وبيقول اهورس
بعد سقوط مملكته كان عنده استعداد يبدل
اغلى شيء في عمره سلطته ملكه مملكته في
مقابل حصان لرغبته في البقاء وانقاذ نفسه
وده انطبق على بطلنا لموته في استعداده
لمقايد التاريخ وبطولاته حتى جواهر حزامه
في مقابل العوده لوقت كان جنبه في عيله
واخ وبيقول
بنفس الاداء المسرحي والدرامي للملك
تشارلز كرغبه قاتله في استعادته لاي جزء
من مجده وبطلنا في حاجه ماسه سواء لمجده
او لعيلته بياكد على دراميه بطلنا موته
وبيبدا العرض الطويل اللي بيدور في 23 سنه
من حياه
قوي جدا من رعب وده شيء مناسب جدا لفنان
اقنع بنفسه المخرج سكرسيزي بالعمل على
الفيلم ده من الاساس
العنف هو البطل والسيد المسيطر على الحدث
والمشهد ولو العنف مش بيدور جوه الحلبه
بيدور براها وده بنشوفه لما بتحصل مشاده
عنيف ما بين الجمهور بتخرج عن السيطره
وبيبقى في تدافع ودهس للناس من الجمهور
ومنعه في الحلبه وجمهورها لعنف جاك لموتا
جوا بيته نفسه وكل حاجه لدرجه شكل اكله
وده بيظهر لنا في مشاده بتحصل ما بيننا
موته ومراته الاولى على درجه تسويه اللحمه
وبيقول لها انها لو فضلت تسوي اللحمه اكتر
من كده يبقى ايه فايدته وجودنا اصلا وهنا
بنعرف ان عنف وحشيه لاموتا ملهاش اي حدود
معينه هنا نوعا ما عايش للالم سواء الم
الشخصي او الم البشر اللي حواليه ما
بيسلمش من قلمه او ايذاءه حتى جاره اللي
جاب بيهدده لمجرد انه رفعوا صوته من شقته
الخاصه علشان يطلب من جاك وامراته ويبطله
ويتخانقوا
العنيفه دي بتظهر مشاهد هاديه بيقدم فيها
سكور سيزي فيكي اهدى وقت الجاك لامودا
بيبقى مع اول ظهور لها عند المسبح واول
تفاعل منهم بيتم على ايد اخوه بيعرفي في
مشهد هو الاهداف حياه لموته بيسلم عليها
بمنتهى الرقه من ورا سور الشبكي بيفصل
محيط المذبح عن الشارع وبيدعوها انهم
يتمشوا سوا بعربيته بعد اكتر المشاهد
هدوءا ده هنرجع تاني لحلبه الملاكمه علشان
نشوف اول فوزه حقيقي لموته ضد رعب وتسجيله
الاول هزيمه لك محترف وبتستمر الاحداث
علشان نشوف تطور حياتنا من خلال تطور
علاقته بيمر شريط طويل بيمثل منحنى الصعود
في حياه لاموتها واخوه بيجمع ما بين مشاهد
زواجه من فيكي واستقراره وانجابهم لاطفال
ونفس الشيء في حياه اخوه وما بين مشاهد
الحلبه عرض شريط الذكريات نفسه كان مهم
جدا في سر احداث الفيلم ما بين مشاهد
سريعه بتعرض شكل حياتهم ومشاهد بطيئه
بتصور في الحلبه في اخر الشريط ان عدى وقت
طويل قوي من حياه لموتا وفيكي واخوه في
وقت قليل جدا كل مشهد في الفيلم بيوصلنا
نتيجه واحده بس وهي ان كورسيزي بيرسم لوحه
كامله من العنف لشخص عنيف والعنف هو تعريف
الوحيد لدرجه ان المشاهد اللطيفه قليله
جدا مع فيكي هتفضل في دماغك لانها غريبه
قوي وفي مقابل مشاهد العنف اللي في الغالب
هتتلخبط فيها هتخرج من الفيلم مش فاكر هو
ضرب اخوه او منافسه في الحلبه او فيك
نفسها كم مره بس هتفضل فاكر مشهد اللطيف
وهو بيتعرف على غير ان احداث العنف
متسارعه جدا في مقابل مشاهد التصوير
البطيء اللي بنشوف فيها غيرته على مثلا
المخرج استخدم السرعه والبطء في التصوير
والمونتاج كويس جدا انه يحفز في دماغك
مشاهد معينه وياهبك المشاهد التانيه وده
كان سبب مهم جدا ان الفيلم فاز بجائزه
احسن مونتاج بعد منحنى الصعود السريع جدا
اللي بيكلل بفوز
واخيرا اقتناصه لقب بطل الوزن المتوسط وفي
نص فيلم بالزبط
يبدا منحنى الهبوط بشكل ابطا المسمار
الاول في نعش هبوط جاك كان قطع علاقته
باخوه وده بعد مشدى عنيفه جدا ما بينه وما
بين اخوه بسبب اتهام بالخيانه بيحصل حدث
صغير ممكن تكون بتعتبره محاوله لعوده
الصعود وهو فوز لموته على دوتيلا هنا فيكي
بتحاول تصلح علاقه لموته باخوه بس لموته
الشخص اللي ظهر عنفه على الجميع عمره ما
اعتذر كان بيكتفي بمحاولات تقرب للاشخاص
اللي بياذيهم فالمشهد بيخلص ان لموته ما
بيعتذرش فعلا وبتظل علاقته باخوه مقطوعه
وهنختم محاولات فوز لموته في الحلبه
بهزيمه ساحقه في الجوله 13 قدام رعب وهنا
هنشوف شكل مختلف تماما وهو الشكل الاقرب
له في مشاهد الكازينو في اول الفيلم لموته
قدام مسبح مع عيلته زوجته واولاده وبيعمل
تصريح صحفي بيقول فيه انه مستعد اخيرا
للتقاعد بيكمل المشهد ظهوره في كازينو
قدام جمهور وهو بيلقي جمله هي جزء من نفس
جملته في المشهد الافتتاحي
الغاضب بمجرد شخص بيلقي لعابات وبيلف على
ناس مختلفه من الجمهور الكازين الخاص بيه
وبعد ده على طول بنشحد تاني مسمار والاخير
في هبوط جاك والمتمثل في تخليه فيكي عنه
واختيارها للطلاق والبعد علشان جاك يلاقي
نفسه لوحده مع غضبه وغيرته ويخسر كوابح
الامان المتمثلين في فيكي واخوه جنب عرض
جاك كان مستوى الذكاء قليل وما بيحسبش
خطواته والوقت هو الشخص الاول والاخير في
القرار فبيستمر في سلسله من القرارات
الحمقاء اللي هتوصله للسجن والوحده وبطل
الوزن المتوسط مش قادر حتى يدفع الكفاله
اللي ممكن تخرجه او حتى قادر يوكل محامي
وده اللي هيوصله لان هو يبيع الجواهر اللي
كانت موجوده على حزامه حزام بطل الوزن
المتوسط وبعد احداث مش واضحه بيخرج فعلا
وبنشوف في كازينو بس المره دي مجرد عامل
الامن في الكازينو
بيظهر لمره اخيره اخوه فبيستاذن الفنانه
الاستعراضيه اللي هو شخصيا المسئول عن
حمايتها وبيتجه لاخوه في محاوله للصلح بس
محاوله متاخره مناقصه جدا ما كانش موجود
فيه حتى عباره اسف حقيقيه وبعدها كمشهد
ختامي بياكد به كرسيزي تاني على مدى
دراميه بطله بيظهر لموتها قدام مرايه
بيلوم اخوه لانه اخوه ولانه في نظره اتخلى
عنه الفيلم رغم انه تعرض لمهجمات كتيره
جدا في اول عرضه وده بسبب مشاهد العنف
الكتير قوي فيه لكن الفيلم حاليا واحد من
اهم الافلام في تاريخ السينما وفي سنه
1990 اصبح الفيلم الاول اللي بيتم اختياره
في عمو الاول من استحقاق حفظه في السجل
الوطني للافلام بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من قبل مكتبه الكونجرس باعتباره
مهم ثقافيا وتاريخيا وصنفوا المعهد
الامريكي للافلام على انه رابع اعظم فيلم
امريكي في كل العصور الفيلم كمان قدم
روبرت دينيرو الحائز على جائزه افضل ممثل
عن الفيلم ده وده بسبب المجهود الكبير
وجوده تم الممتازه كمان دي نيرو اكتسب
اكتر من 29 باوند خلال التصوير علشان يصور
حقيقه تطور جسد لموته خلال 23 سنه بس في
خلال مده الفيلم اللي على الشاشه ما
بتتعداش الساعتين احد اهم عوامل نجاح
الفيلم والضمان له جايزه تانيه جنب افضل
ممثل كان افضل منتج واللي بتلمسه كمشاهد
بمنتهى الوضوح وفي نص الفيلم وفي نص شريط
ذكريات طويل رغم قصص مدته بينقل لك طول
حياه لموتا وبيكلم نجاحه وبيمهد لك رحله
سقوط بالسرعه والبطء الكافيين واخيرا كل
اللي محتاجه في الوقت ده انك تشوف الفيلم
لو ما شفتوش ولو شفته شارك فيه وازاي شفت
شخصيات الابطال واستناني الحلقه اللي جايه
في حلقه جديده من بودكا الافلام علشان
نحكي عن ما وراء فيلم جديد بمنظور مختلف
منظور ما وراء الافلام
[موسيقى]